أريد أن أضع صورًا مرة أخرى
لمحطة زاباريسا للطاقة النووية، ما حجم
الكارثة التي ستحدث من
وجهة نظر استراتيجية إذا قامت روسيا
بتخريب هذه المحطة
جيدًا، شكرًا لك جون حسنًا، ستكون هذه
كارثة ضخمة
من الناحية التشغيلية والاستراتيجية،
أعني أنها أه  توجد بعض
أغنى الأراضي الزراعية في العالم على بعد
50 إلى 100 ميل من هذه المنشأة، وهي
أكبر محطة للطاقة النووية في أوروبا،
وهذا يؤثر بشكل لا يصدق على
الإمدادات الغذائية العالمية، ناهيك عن
التهديد بالطبع بفقدان
الأرواح و  لا شيء، ولهذا السبب
يتعين على اللجنة الدولية للطاقة الذرية أن تكثف بشكل مطلق إرسال
مفتشين إلى هناك وتؤكد أو
تنفي حالة الوضع هناك،
والشيء الآخر الذي أعتقد أن
العمليات على الأرض تشير إليه
هو أن استعادة السيطرة على زاباريسيا
أولوية قصوى لهذا
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني، لذا فهم بحاجة أيضًا إلى
تصعيده. فلاديمير بوتين يائس، لقد
رأينا ما فعله أه رد فعله على
انشقاق مجموعة فاغنر مؤخرًا، لقد
أصبح
ضعيفًا بشكل متزايد داخليًا وبالتالي ليس هناك
حدود لما  قد يكون هذا الموت للرجال
مفيدًا جدًا، فقد قام بالفعل بتدمير
السد الذي لديه القدرة على التأثير على بعض
تلك الخزانات الستة التي
أشار إليها سكوت للتو والمنشأة لأن
هذا أه هذا الزاباريسيا عبارة عن
مفاعل ماء مضغوط، وكان تشيرنوبيل
مفاعلًا معالجًا بالجرافيت  ما
يعنيه ذلك هو أنهم بحاجة إلى المياه
وأبراج المياه والتبريد
ومرافق الاحتواء وكل هذه الأشياء مصنوعة
من الخرسانة، كما تعلمون،
ويمكن لأسلحة الحرب أن تدمر تلك
الهياكل الخرسانية، لذا فإن هذا يمثل
تهديدًا خطيرًا وعلينا أن نتحرك  الأمر مع
الهيئة الدولية للطاقة الذرية وعمليا على
الأرض